très bien chers collègues
désolé de
3 minutes de retard donc nous entendons
ce matin le professeur Christelle gras
legen le Gwen
en téléconférence et Adrien taquelle que
nous connaissons bien cette commission
et qui est les deux sont qu'au président
du comité d'orientation des Assises de
la pédiatrie et la santé de l'enfant
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat
nous accueillons par ailleurs une
délégation de fonctionnaires de
l'Assemblée nationale d'Arménie sur la
barre conduite par son secrétaire
général qui assiste à notre à vos ce
matin et je les salue en votre nom à
tous les assises de la pédiatrie ont été
lancé en décembre dernier dans un
contexte de tension extrême des services
d'urgence pédiatriques
avec une épidémie de bronchiolite à la
fois très virulente et très précoce mais
aussi une suite situation
structurelle très dégradée nous sommes
d'ailleurs allés avec quelques membres
d'un Commission à l'hôpital Necker en
décembre pour voir la situation
leur champ
oui le chant des assises
englobe toutefois tous les
professionnels intervenants dans la
santé de l'enfant que ce soit en ville à
l'hôpital mais aussi les services
scolaires et de santé scolaire ou encore
les services de protection maternelle et
infantile les assises doivent aboutir au
printemps à l'adoption d'une feuille de
route en 6 points dont je ne relèverai
qu'un seul relevez le défi de la santé
mentale des enfants de nombreux travaux
ont été consacrés par le Sénat à ce
sujet qui ont souligné l'ampleur du défi
à relever et je vous laisse tout de
suite la parole madame la professeure et
Monsieur le Ministre pour nous présenter
l'état d'avancement de vos travaux avant
que nos collègues ne vous posent les
questions nous disposons d'une heure
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente bonjour Christelle
à distance est-il possible on a un petit
support de présentation ce qui est
possible qu'il soit
partagé à tout le monde d'accord mais
est-ce que
les membres de la commission peuvent aux
gens madame la sénatrice
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup ravi de vous retrouver ce matin
pour évoquer effectivement les assises
de la santé de l'enfant assises de la
pédiatrie et de la santé de l'enfant et
merci madame la Présidente effectivement
nous avons échangé ensemble il me
semblait intéressant et important
surtout de pouvoir venir devant vous ce
matin partager avec vous ce que sont les
grands les grands axes la méthode et les
attendus de cette de ces assises de ce
processus qui a lancé effectivement
comme le rappeler madame la Présidente
le ministre François abrone en plein
milieu de la crise des urgences
pédiatriques et de voir comment vous
parlementaire et en particulier les
sénateurs qui être peut-être encore plus
en prise avec les problématiques de vos
territoires des élus locaux comment vous
pouvez contribuer à cette réflexion à
cette réflexion collective on est à la
présidente l'évoquait en hiver dernier
nous avons été notre pays a été conf
commencé à cette à ce qui est en réalité
malheureusement un marronnier
un rendez-vous annuel qui est celui de
la crise des urgences pédiatriques mais
qui a été particulièrement aigu cette
année du fait de la conjonction d'une
triple épidémie
épidémie de la covid et puis des MI de
la grippe et épidémie de la bronchiolite
et avec une dette immunitaire qui était
ce qu'elle a été du fait de ces deux
dernières années où nous avons tenté de
nous protéger du covid qui a fait que
cette triple épidémie a été
particulièrement
importante et a donc saturé les urgences
avec un manque de lit d'hospitalisation
conventionnel et en soins critiques une
périnate en difficulté des équipes déjà
éprouvées mais plus épuisé encore et
avec des démissions qui ont continué
d'augmenter et une permanence des soins
qui est devenue particulièrement
problématique mais tout cela en réalité
n'est que la face immergée
de l'iceberg et ce dont il est question
ce n'est pas simplement une crise des
urgences pédiatriques mais bien une
crise de notre système global de prise
en charge de la santé de l'enfant des
PMI vous connaissez bien qui sont en
difficulté ils ont fait vertus et ces
dernières années de les de les de les de
les soutenir de réinvestir néanmoins il
y a encore des manques de moyens il y a
encore en dépit des délégations de
compétences du temps médical disponible
insuffisant et vous le savez c'était le
rapport Péron sur la PMI de 2018
75 à 80 % des médecins de PMI qui
étaient en poste il y a encore trois
quatre ans qui seront à la retraite dans
dans les années les toutes proches
années à venir la médecine scolaire
y a-t-il encore une médecine scolaire
quand il reste 800 médecins scolaires
dans notre pays je pense c'est la
question il faut se poser comme tel
manque de pédopsychiatre vous avez parlé
de santé mentale madame la Présidente
vous le savez là aussi quelques
centaines en France et manque de
spécialistes dans de nombreuses
spécialités de l'enfant en réalité au
delà de la seule pédopsychiatrie et puis
dans certaines cmpj des délais
d'attentes dans certains territoires de
6 à 12 mois qui sont autant de pertes de
chances pour nos enfants
etc etc voilà donc au-delà de la crise
des urgences pédiatriques c'est bien
l'ensemble de notre système de prise en
charge de la santé de l'enfant qui est
confronté à des difficultés aujourd'hui
qui sont des défiles cultés systémiques
et qu'il convient de refonder pour les
pour les enfants qui naissent
aujourd'hui et pour ceux qui naîtront
demain et donc c'est toute l'ambition de
ces assises de la pédiatrie et qu'on a
voulu tourner comme des Assises de la
santé de l'enfant pour parler davantage
des enfants peut-être que de que de ceux
qui en prennent qui en prennent en
prennent soin même si bien évidemment
ils sont au cœur de nos de nos travaux
et de nos réflexions assises de la
pédiatrie la santé de l'enfant qui ont
été annoncés par le ministre de la Santé
de la prévention François Brown le 29
novembre dernier
l'objectif de ces assises l'objectif de
ces assis c'est d'abord de dépasser le
constat on en est plus au stade du
constat ce constat ça fait 10 15 20 ans
que nous le faisons tous que nous le
partageons
et donc véritablement l'objectif de ces
assises c'est de passer
aux mesures concrètes à ce plan d'action
plus réelle de refondation de la santé
de l'enfant les assises ça sera pas un
colloque de deux jours on va se dire à
quel point ça va mal ça ne sera pas
l'occasion de faire tribune ça sera
l'occasion véritablement de proposer un
plan de refondation de notre système de
santé avec quelques principes directeurs
que je vous que je vous partage quand on
parle d'enfant il a été décidé de parler
d'enfants de 0 à 18 ans c'était une
question qui n'est pas neutre notamment
en santé mentale avec une attention
particulière qui doit être portée à ces
fameuses périodes de transition ou en
France qui sont souvent synonymes de
rupture dans les prises en charge pour
les pour les personnes
entre 18 ans et l'âge adulte mais il y a
d'autres périodes de transition au cours
du parcours de soins de l'enfant plus
jeune santé évidemment enfin évidemment
santé globale au sens de l'OMS physique
mental social culturel l'environnemental
bref dans l'ensemble de ses composantes
une approche parcours de santé par
besoin des enfants et de leurs parents
ont vraiment ses vertus à partir de
l'enfant à partir de ses besoins et non
pas des compétences des uns ou des
autres ou des spécialités des uns et des
autres mais bien des besoins de l'enfant
essayez de faire de l'enfant et de ses
parents des acteurs de santé
enfin je vous le disais des mesures des
propositions de mesure concrètes et puis
on aura une temporalité comme souvent
dans ces grands plans et ces grandes
stratégies des temporalités de cours et
de moyens termes dans les mesures il y a
des choses qui pourraient être adopter
immédiatement d'ailleurs le timing est
tel qu'il est pour pouvoir
dans le cadre du prochain PLFSS embarqué
un certain nombre de mesures qui
pourraient qui pourraient l'être donc il
y aura une mise en oeuvre immédiate et
puis des choses qui par construction par
nature je pense notamment à la refonte
des diplômes des carrières le régime
d'autorisation qui prennent un peu plus
de temps
seront à plus moyen terme probablement
la méthode la méthode c'est celle de la
concertation voulue par le ministre la
plus large possible la plus large
possible auprès de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé et au-delà pas
que des professionnels de santé de
toutes les personnes qui ont
très de près ou de loin à la santé de
l'enfant et puis bien évidemment aussi
de toutes les autres parties prenantes
font partie notamment pas que les élus
et les élus les élus locaux le timing la
présidente l'évoquais
ces assises auront lieu avant l'été
et ça sera l'occasion pour le ministre
d'annoncer sa feuille de route partir
des besoins de l'enfant partant de là
nous avons déterminé 6 axes de travail
que je vais vous présenter qui sont
animés chacun de ces actes sont animés
par 18 copilotes qui sont des
professionnels de santé et des
paramédicaux et nous sommes donc deux
coprésidents à animer l'ensemble de ces
de ces travaux au sein d'un comité
d'orientation donc Christelle gras Le
Guen donc avec nous en présentiel enfin
en distanciel pardon et qui s'excuse de
son de son absence qui est chef du
service de pédiatrie générale les
urgences pédiatriques du CHU de Nantes
et qui est par ailleurs président de la
Société française de pédiatrie voilà et
c'est notamment toute l'équipe avec
Nathalie vavre Martin balançon qui
travaille beaucoup très impliqué et
pionniers sur les yeux à peine c'est une
unité d'accueil pédiatrique de l'enfant
sont en danger et puis par moi-même que
vous connaissez nous avons eu l'occasion
de travailler ensemble donc en partant
des besoins de l'enfant nous avons
déterminé 6 axes de travail
totalement rigoureux honnête c'est
surtout les quatre premiers premier
c'est garantir à tous les enfants à
parcours de santé de qualité et sans
rupture le deuxième
vise à améliorer le parcours en santé
des enfants les plus fragiles je vais
revenir rapidement sur chacun d'entre
eux question de la santé mentale qui
évoquait la la présidente la question de
la prévention évidemment importante et
puis enfin les deux derniers axes qui
sont plus enfin qui sont transversaux
évidemment à tous les autres la question
de la formation professionnelle et des
carrières
sujets important évidemment et enfin
tout ce qui a trait à la recherche et
aux pratiques innovantes
voilà pour ces pour ces six axes que je
vous détaille là aussi très rapidement
l'axe 1 c'est vraiment c'est la question
du droit commun
comment on s'assure que 95% des enfants
en bonne santé dans ce pays ont de leur
naissance
voir un petit peu avant qu'on ferait les
1000 jours jusqu'à leur 18 ans un
parcours de santé qui soit de qualité il
l'est sommes en France ne vont quand
même être satisfait d'être dans le pays
dans lequel nous sommes mais qui peut
être probablement de plus grande qualité
encore qu'aujourd'hui et sans rupture là
mal très français que vous que l'on
connaît bien
et donc c'est toute la question derrière
évidemment de la naissance c'est la
question de la médecine scolaire c'est
la question des PMI c'est la question
des professionnels de santé général
pédiatrie générale et des spécialités
voilà c'est tous ces sujets là qui à
l'occasion de cet axe de comment recréer
un parcours de santé de qualité sans
rupture pour l'ensemble des enfants de
ce territoire toutes ces questions là
qu'il faudra aborder
et donc la question des questions qui
vous sont peut-être un peu plus chères
encore que d'autres Protection
Maternelle et Infantile notamment
médecine scolaire qui a fait l'objet de
débat en cette maison il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça et il y a un rapport
souvenez-vous sortie des discussions sur
la loi 4DS 3DS 4DS 3 c'était 3
finalement je ne sais je ne sais plus
pardon d'accord on était en était revenu
à tourner des revenus à trois pardon
il voyait aucune validité
c'est la question de la médecine
scolaire a rapport avait été il y a une
mission en cours de l'inspection
générale de l'éducation au final et de
des affaires sociales sur ce sujet là et
qui sera bien évidemment intégré à
toutes nos réflexions le rôle de cristal
et de moi-même et évidemment d'aussi
coordonner tous les travaux qui ont
cours en ce moment sur les différents
sujets que nous évoquons voilà et vous
avez à chaque fois les pilotes vous
voyez qu'il y a à la fois des pays pH
des libéraux infirmiers puéricultère qui
sont bien bien représentés notre amant
grâce à Charles des médecins générales
des personnes qui exercent en PMI
d'autres en à l'hôpital enfin voilà on a
essayé on n'a pas pu représenter tout le
monde c'était pas la vocation de ces de
ses actes et puis il n'aurait pas été
possible de représenter tout le monde
puisqu'il y a quand même beaucoup de
monde mais c'est la méthode et j'y
reviendrai c'est bien de concerter tout
le monde d'écouter tout le monde et que
tout le monde prenne pas à assez assise
et c'est la dynamique qui est en cours
le deuxième axe c'est porte sur les
enfants que j'ai appelé les enfants
fragiles
ou les enfants a besoin spécifiques au
sens large plus large que seulement le
handicap ça concerne tout d'abord les
enfants qui souffrent de maladies
chroniques rares ou complexes évidemment
deuxième
[Musique]
enfant concerné ce sont les enfants a
besoin spécifique les enfants en
situation de handicap alors oui c'est
tout ce qui a créé aux soins des enfants
du handicap repérage notamment on pense
aux troubles neuro-développementaux mais
pas que et moi j'attache une importation
toute particulière à l'accès aux soins
les plus élémentaires des enfants en
situation de handicap c'est un peu un
angle mort un oubli voilà comment un
gamin avec un truc du spectre de
l'autisme par exemple qui a du mal à
même qu'on s'approche de lui trop près
parce que il y a un problème de
proximité physique quand il doit aller
la première fois chez le dentiste
comment ça se passe généralement ça se
passe mal voilà jeune femme
avec une déficience mentale ou
paraplégique qui doit avoir sa première
consultation de gynécologie parce que ça
commence à se passe généralement ça se
passe pas très bien non plus
donc il y a un vrai sujet de l'accès aux
soins les plus primaires élémentaires
des enfants en situation de handicap
avec des problèmes des aspects liés à la
formation notamment des professionnels
de santé troisième objectif c'est la
lutte contre la précarité en santé
beaucoup de enfants beaucoup trop
d'enfants de notre pays qui sont en
situation de pauvreté vous connaissez
les vous connaissez les chiffres on sait
que ce sont des facteurs aggravants un
certain nombre de composantes en santé
merci et donc cet aspect là doit être
aussi évidemment traité quatrième
objectif que j'ai souhaité qu'il figure
comme un objectif en tant que tel parce
que ça aussi c'est souvent
bien vu dans les projets de loi souvent
l'article un peu à la fin du projet de
loi souvent des choses qu'on nommait
c'est la question les outre-mer voilà il
y a un certain nombre de particularités
de prévalence dans les outre-mer on n'a
pas en territoire métropolitain et qu'il
va falloir là aussi tenter de régler
d'affronter aussi sans tabou parce qu'il
y a deux trois tabouches je pense qu'il
va falloir briser sur les questions
liées à la santé à la santé des enfants
sont et sexuelles ou autres
j'ai Saché que j'ai sollicité la
délégation du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale aux outre-mer pour procéder au
même au même exercice auquel je me prête
et pour pour que la délégation ait ses
membres puissent contribuer
contribuer à la réflexion et aux
propositions
et je suis en attente de réponse de la
part de la délégation je passe un petit
message en passant cinquième objectif
voilà absolument j'ai écrit à Stéphane
les enfants de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance vous connaissez bien le sujet
là aussi il s'avère que ses enfants qui
sont pourtant sous nos yeux et sous
notre protection sont en moins bonne
santé et même quand ils sortent de leur
parcours en protection de l'enfance
c'est ça qui est incroyable ils sont en
moins bonne santé que les autres gamins
de leur âge voilà donc comment faire en
sorte d'améliorer la santé des enfants
protégés et puis enfin dernier dernière
objectif le dépistage et enfin les
enfants victimes de violence comment
continuer le travail qu'on a initié
ensemble les années passées pour mieux
repérer pour mieux prendre en soin mieux
prendre en charge mieux soigner
l'ensemble des enfants victimes de
violences sexuelles mais pas que il y a
des choses qui sont faites il y a des
choses qui ont été mises en place mais
il y a encore des choses à
intensifier voilà donc un certain nombre
de sujets où là aussi vous avez une
affinité peut-être un peu un peu plus
particulière encore que sur le reste je
pense évidemment à l'aide sociale en
France je pensais évidemment aux enfants
en situation de handicap je pense à
l'Outre-mer pour les élus
ultramarins
troisième axe la santé mentale
là aussi avec des des pilotes je suis
passé rapidement sur les pilotes
précédents mais vous avez pu voir
vous-même voilà avec la présence de
Guillaume Brossard la sur la santé
mentale qui est là en tant que PUPH mais
surtout en tant que président de la
Maison des Adolescents puisqu'il y a
évidemment tout le sujet de la
prévention en santé mentale aussi il y a
eu des Assises de la santé mentale
souvenez-vous en novembre 2021 conclut
par le Président de la République ou un
certain d'annonces ont été faites
notamment sur la pédopsychiatrie c'est
vers tuer à mon ministère de faire un
certain nombre de choses mais il y a
encore beaucoup à faire évidemment et
c'est pour ça qu'on a voulu qu'il y ait
un axe qui soit dédié à la santé mentale
sujet de préoccupation majeure et
croissant encore dans notre pays
s'agissant des sagissant des jeunes avec
à la fois donc Lamon la prévention mais
aussi tout ce qui avale et
l'articulation entre prédom psychiatrie
et pédiatrie où il y a vraiment des
binômes à créer enfin une approche
conjointe à probablement améliorer et
mieux articuler quatrième axe la
question de la prévention
vous avez deux un médecin de PMI Corinne
bois qui est dans les dans l'Essonne et
puis Loïc de pontuel qui est à Jean
Verdi à Bondy et avec là on va retrouver
elles ne sont pas citées là enfin elles
sont citées à la fin mais toutes les
grandes politiques de prévention en
santé publique
que vous connaissez les addictions un
sujet sur la santé physique
puisqu'on a mangé bouger on a beaucoup
parlé de manger ces dernières années
mais le côté bouger probablement des
choses à faire et puis on voit par
ailleurs que les chiffres d'obésité de
l'enfance
évolue mal dans notre dans notre pays
des la question des addictions aux
écrans évidemment un sujet qui tient je
crois à coeur le ministre qui est la
question qui est pas totalement dénué de
lien avec celui que je viens de citer et
qui est la question du sommeil
des enfants voilà c'est un vrai sujet de
santé publique voilà et puis avec une
dimension
alors dumperment je sais pas quel terme
français mais que c'est aussi derrière
ces sujets de prévention c'est comment
on fait des enfants des acteurs de leur
propre santé et comment on fait des
parents des acteurs de la santé de leur
enfant voilà c'est aussi un élément de
réflexion que les que les pilotes
prennent en compte
axe 5 la question de la formation
et des carrières donc là des grands
chantiers
délégation de compétences les maquettes
les maquettes universitaires les
pratiques avancées bref tout est toutes
ces tendances qu'on commence à avoir
depuis quelques années sont évidemment
sur la table voilà le rôle du médecin
général le rôle de la gradation des
soins du médecin généraliste bon
beaucoup de beaucoup de sujets
importants qui sont un peu au coeur
évidemment des quatre autres axes que
vous avez vu précédemment et puis le
dernier axe la question de la recherche
assez peu de recherches en pédiatrie
comment on fait pour améliorer ça pour
stimuler ça et puis tout une réflexion
également sur les pratiques innovantes
voilà pour sortir peut-être à l'âge du
numérique de la relation un peu dû à
exclusive entre le médecin et son
patient peut-être d'autres pratiques que
l'on peut que l'on peut imaginer voilà
et avec notamment Martin chalumeau de
Necker en forme malade que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure voilà pour voilà pour ces
six axes leur contenu leur pilote alors
comment on participe aux assises les
sésame ces pilotes que vous avez vu leur
rôle sur chacun de leur axe c'est de
concerter le plus largement possible par
le biais d'audition de table ronde de
déplacement ils sont assez libres dans
leur façon de faire dans
l'identification de pratique innovante
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose sur
lequel on pourra revenir parce que c'est
peut-être des choses que vous pouvez
nous faire remonter de vos territoires
en particulier on a ouvert la
possibilité de faire des contributions
écrites qui sont ouverts à tout le monde
à la fois la société aux sociétés
savantes aux associations aux individus
au parlementaires à titre individuel
s'il le souhaite donc vous pouvez
retrouver le lien sur le site du
ministère ou sur le site de la Société
française de pédiatrie
et puis il y a une adresse mail aussi
auquel on peut envoyer les contributions
sachez qu'aujourd'hui sur cet espace que
nous avons créé pour les contributions
écrites nous en sommes après 600
contributions voilà sur l'ensemble de
ces axes donc il y a vraiment une
volonté très collective et collaborative
sachez pour être totalement complet
qu'il m'a été aussi évidemment sans
grande surprise j'ai eu très à coeur de
prendre en compte la parole de l'enfant
lui-même parce que c'est quand même de
lui dont on parle et donc nous lançons
nous sommes en train de lancer une
consultation auprès des enfants
n'ont pas sur l'ensemble des sujets des
assises mais sur un sujet de prévention
qui sera très probablement celui de la
l'activité physique justement de la
santé et de la santé physique on va
d'une part faire travailler le conseil
de l'enfance du hcfe1 et par ailleurs en
s'appuyant sur la méthodologie qui a
développé le Défenseur des enfants
depuis 2019 et sont et sont pour son
rapport annuel en s'appuyant sur un
certain nombre de têtes de réseau faire
travailler là aussi des enfants en
protection de l'enfance des conseils
municipaux des jeunes de l'éducation
populaire enfin voilà de différents
profils sur ce sur ce sujet là sachez
par ailleurs que nous consultons les
parents nous avons lancé une grande
enquête avec Luna c'est ce qu'on avait
déjà avec eux dans le cadre de la
Conférence des familles sur la question
de l'articulation entre vie pro et vie
perso avec une phase à la fois
qualitative où on fait des tables rondes
avec des parents et puis quantitatives
ils vont interroger à travers tous les
UDAF les familles françaises pour savoir
quelle est la perception qu'on les
familles françaises de la santé de leur
enfant
et de la façon dont celle-ci est prise
en charge par les points publics voilà
il sachez enfin qu'il y a un comité des
partis prenantes aussi qui serait mis
toutes les 6 à 8 semaines très très
large pour que nous puissions partager
avec toutes les personnes concernées
l'état d'avancement des travaux le
planning contribution aux assises de
janvier en gros à mi-mars fin mars 2023
avril mai ça sera le temps de la de la
mise en cohérence de tout cela et de
l'écriture du plan et puis
assise de la santé de l'enfant et donc
les annonces de ce plan d'action par le
ministre entre mi-mai mi-juin une
fenêtre une fenêtre large avec une date
qui n'est pas encore encore déterminée
mais qui se situera avant l'été puisque
ça a été la promesse du ministre
sachez pour être vraiment totalement
complet que j'ai donc sollicité une
audition devant votre commission de la
même façon devant la commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale les délégations outremergent
je les dis et bien évidemment
l'Assemblée des départements de France
j'ai échangé avec François Sauvadet
Frédéric Bierry et Florence Dabin pour
la partie enfance et donc j'ai proposé
là aussi d'aller présenter la méthode
devant l'Assemblée départements de
France et que l'assemblée départements
de France sur ces différents sujets et
puis il y a le handicap aussi bien sûr
et surtout tout ce que l'assemblée
souhaite puisse contribuer de façon
écrite ou orale
aux assises et de la même façon contact
et prix avec l'Association des régions
de France l'association des maires de
France et mon journaliste et puis avec
l'association des mers ruraux de France
aussi avec qui je dois également prendre
contact voilà un peu pour les
institutionnels une présentation et une
contribution est attendue également de
la part du scène CPH c'est national
consultative des personnes handicapées
le hcfa ou également été sollicité voilà
un peu pour toutes les sollicitations
institutionnelles et donc la question
madame prison donc vous voyez nous en
sommes encore c'est très méthode ce dont
ce que je suis venu vous présenter les
travaux sont en cours donc je à votre
disposition nous sommes avec Christelle
à votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions bien entendu et vous
comprendrez bien que sur des questions
si vous nous posez des questions de fond
j'aurais tendance à vous répondre que
c'est des sujets qui sont en cours de
travaux mais toute la question en sortie
aussi de cette de cette audition et de
voir comment dans les semaines à venir
vous souhaitez ou pas et sous une forme
qui vous appartient à titre individuel
évidemment ou en tant que commission
prendre part à ces assises et moi je
suis tout à fait ouvert à ce que nous
nous revoyons d'une forme ou d'une autre
dans les semaines à venir si vous le
souhaitez voilà merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup en effet
avant de passer la parole à Madame le
professeur
pour compléter ce qui a été dit
notamment sur le handicap la commission
des affaires sociales à lancer une
mission sur les troubles du
neuro-développement mission qui sera
pilotée par
par Jocelyne gitès lamburgo et Corinne
et puis nous avons créé un groupe
d'études handicap à la demande du
président Larcher qui est présidé par
par Philippe mouillé moi j'avais une
première question qui était
l'articulation avec les ministères bon
c'est François Brune qui a lancé les
assises de la pédiatrie je suppose que
vous travaillez aussi avec avec
Charlotte cobel sur sur l'enfance
comment ça se passe ce point là mais
peut-être avant que vous répondiez on va
passer la parole à Madame professeur qui
va nous donner compléter ce qu'a dit
Adrien taquet peut-être nous expliquer
aussi ce qui se passait à Nantes avec le
projet bronchioli et tout ça
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente et
merci de cette opportunité de pouvoir
échanger avec avec vous sur un sujet qui
nous tient vraiment à coeur et la santé
de l'enfant et qui a été vraiment
malmené vous l'avez vous l'avez entendu
sur la fin d'année 2022 et pour lequel
on souhaiterait vraiment que des mesures
soient possibles des les prochains mois
pour éviter de revivre ça en fin 2023
d'une part mais comme vous l'a très bien
expliqué Adrien taquet ce n'est que la
partie visible du problème et que la
santé de l'enfant ne se résume pas à
l'embouteillage aux urgences
pédiatriques en fin d'année mais bien à
un problème beaucoup plus vaste en amont
et en aval de cette période et qui
nécessite concis attelle de manière
collective et donc c'était c'était un
des objectifs de notre regroupe que de
pouvoir rassembler le plus de de
personnes concernées par la santé de
l'enfant de manière à avoir une vue qui
soit vraiment très générale de leurs
différents parcours de soins et pouvoir
porter ensemble à l'échelle nationale
des mesures qui ne seraient pas
uniquement ciblé sur
une étape de leur parcours de soi mais
bien l'ensemble des parcours de soins
donc pour cela il y a beaucoup il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'idées qui existent
déjà il y a déjà des innovations il y a
déjà des initiatives dans beaucoup
d'endroits en France qui fonctionnent et
donc l'objectif de notre travail avec
Adrien taquet c'est vraiment de pouvoir
coordonner toutes ces bonnes idées
toutes ces initiatives tout ce qu'on
connaît déjà vous avez mentionné un
certain nombre de travaux qui sont en
cours mais il y en a déjà qui ont abouti
dernièrement qui sont des mines d'or en
termes de d'information et de et de
bonnes idées et donc on ne va pas
repartir de zéro bien évidemment mais
pouvoir s'appuyer sur tout ce qui existe
tout ce que vous connaissez tout ce qui
qui est susceptible de très mis en avant
comme des solutions pour le cours et
aussi le plus long terme puisque nous
sommes ambitieux vous l'avez entendu non
seulement on s'intéresse à l'ensemble du
parcours de soins mais on se projette
aussi dans le système de santé de
l'enfant pour les 5 ou 10 prochaines
années donc à ce titre on a besoin de
réforme de fond sur des parcours qui
sont vastes et donc on a besoin de
toutes les bonnes volontés de toutes les
bonnes idées et de pouvoir partager avec
vous sur sur les prochaines semaines
puisque le calendrier vous l'avez
entendu et contraint et que il va
falloir pouvoir se mettre en lien dans
les prochaines semaines sur les
propositions et les contributions afin
de
de pouvoir avancer rapidement sur les
perspectives et les propositions
concrètes
très bien
Adrien je peux vous répondre à la
question vous avez raison de me poser la
question était pertinent sur la question
de l'articulation avec les mystères
comme souvent dans des sujets qui ont
très à l'enfance c'est intrinsèquement
interministériel et là il en est de la
il en est de même donc évidemment piloté
par par François Braun mais nous
travaillons et les membres de différents
cabinets font partie du comité
d'orientation nous travaillons et des
cavité des parties prenantes nous
travaillons avec Jean-François combe
Jean-Christophe combe pardon excusez-moi
pour les sujets de précarité en santé
parce qu'il y a des il y a des
réflexions en cours sur la question du
handicap absolument et ainsi qu'avec
Geneviève dariussec avec papendaye pour
la question de la médecine scolaire avec
Sylvie retaillod tout ce qui a très aux
formations aux carrières c'est le
mystère aussi de l'enseignement
supérieur avec l'outre-mer très
probablement à qui je n'ai pas encore
pris contact mais vous avez compris que
c'était un des sujets que je voulais que
ce qui soit abordés au sein de ces
assises donc oui nous travaillons bien
et avec Charlotte Coppel évidemment vous
avez commencé pareil à juste titre
pour ces assises donc nous travaillons
et c'est le rôle le rôle beaucoup de
cristal moi-même et d'assurer la bonne
fluidité la coordination la coopération
de l'ensemble des personnes impliquées
et ça vaut pour les pour les ministres
et les ministères
Corinne question
Bernard bonne
merci Madame présidente merci à tous les
deux pour en tout cas la présentation de
la méthode qui me paraît effectivement
très claire et très collégiale une
peut-être une première question puisque
vous savez évidemment qu'il y a eu un
rapport de ligace avec 21 propositions
qui qui ont été faites 21
recommandations dirons-nous certaines
n'auraient pu être mise en oeuvre déjà
l'année dernière donc quelle plus-value
ces assises apporteront-elles regardent
des propositions déjà formulées
puisqu'elles sont déjà formulées quel
est votre analyse de ces recommandations
le projet
bronchiolib que la présidente a évoqué
juste à l'instant qui a été mise en
place à Nantes en 2019 madame la
professeur pouvez-vous nous dresser un
bilan de ce projet et le bilan pouvant
évidemment mettre être mis à l'actif de
ce projet à qui de te reconduit cet
hiver ou bien produit-il encore des
effets votre service a-t-il pu davantage
résisté à l'épisode épidémie de cet
hiver que dans d'autres territoires
bien évidemment et je vous l'avais dit
tout à l'heure
cette vision elle est globale elle ne
concerne pas que la médecine générale
mais beaucoup de secteurs sont en
difficulté que ce soit en ville à
l'hôpital la PMI la médecine scolaire
souvent soit pour un problème
d'attractivité les conseils
départementaux régulièrement nous disent
qu'ils ont des difficultés par exemple à
recruter des médecins pour pour la PMI
êtes-vous assuré de pouvoir envisager
des mesures qui seront suivies par des
efforts budgétaires avez-vous des
engagements du gouvernement sur ce point
à un moment donné aux a dit bah voilà
ces quartiers libres et ça coûterait ce
que ça coûtera pour parler simplement ou
au contraire
et bien prenant des mesures déjà qui
marche généralisons-les avec évidemment
une maîtrise des dépenses que nous
pouvons entendre et évidemment nous
sommes toujours tous atrachés très
attentif à au territoire quel impact
d'ores et déjà peut-on envisager pour
les conseils départementaux
côté prévention quel bilan faites-vous
des vaccinations obligatoires de
l'enfant qui ont été étendues depuis
2018 ce que vous avez déjà apporté un
regard là dessus et puis vous avez
évoqué les outre-mer de toute façon pas
que vous auriez un regard attentif aux
outre-mer une délégation de la
Commission s'est rendue l'année dernière
à Mayotte et puis par exemple constater
que toute la chirurgie infantile repose
sur des transferts vers la Réunion
voilà est-ce que ce sujet là sera par
exemple
une attention très très pertinente lors
de lors de vos travaux je vous remercie
vraiment de penser mon
président de Monsieur Merci sur le
ministre pour ces cette présentation de
la méthode de cette assise vous avez un
moment donné moi j'ai vraiment une
réponse une question au tac au tac vous
avez un moment donné évoqué la santé
physique de l'enfant vous avez dit
manger bouger et très vite et sommeil et
dormir et je me demandais dans le cas
des y compris de transversale de vos
liens avec un terminal si vous pensiez
quand même documenter voir faire refaire
des recherches d'évaluation sur sur
l'articulation entre le temps et le
rythme scolaire
sur il y a des travaux de chronobiologie
mais
quand même il y a des travaux mais
quelque part c'est un sujet qui revient
régulièrement donc du temps et du rythme
scolaire sur le rythme de vie de
l'enfant sur Saint sur l'impact sur son
sommeil et sur son rythme de sommeil
quoi est-ce que c'est un un chantier que
vous allez rouvrir parce que il est
quand même absolument déterminant je
pense pour beaucoup de sujets mais
surtout pour le dormir que vous avez
évoqué
Narbonne
merci madame la Présidente oui moi je
vais m'accès un peu plus sur le la
protection de l'enfance bien sûr mais
parler d'abord des 1000 premiers jours
la qui avait été mise en place et dans
ces 1000 premiers jours on devait
renforcer les moyens de la PMI et je
voulais savoir
votre départ du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre est-ce que vous savez où on en
est justement de ces renforts au niveau
des services de PMI qui semble encore
relativement défaillant est-ce que vous
pensez que les vos successeurs poussent
un peu justement à ces renforts de la
PMI dans les départements la deuxième
question c'est parmi les grands axes de
ces assises figure l'objectif
d'améliorer la santé des enfants
protégés tout au long de leur parcours
en protection
et on avait depuis la loi de 2016 on
avait des bilans de santé qui étaient
obligatoires est-ce que vous en avez pas
pu évaluer l'effectivité de ces bilans
obligatoires lors de la lors de l'examen
de la loi sur la protection de l'enfance
est-ce que vous savez où on en est
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils sont vraiment
obligatoire est-ce qu'ils sont vraiment
mis en place dans chaque département et
quels sont les obstacles justement qui
qui empêche que ces bilans soient
réellement fait et puis plus globalement
comment on pourrait améliorer la
coordination du parcours de soins de des
enfants protégés et est-ce que vous
étudiez la piste d'une généralisation de
l'expérimentation santé protégée qui
permet grâce à une rémunération
forfaitaire d'identifier des médecins
qui acceptent de structurer les parcours
de soins des enfants merci monsieur le
ministre
très bien vous voulez répondre en
continu oui
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de questions
Christelle peut-être je réponds sur
quelques-unes et puis je vous laisse sur
d'autres de façon totalement arbitrage
arbitraire et autoritaire
alors
[Musique]
madame la sénatrice Imbert Corinne
Imbert et ça sera ça sera complété je
pense également par Christelle Graal et
wenzo le rapport igua c'est évidemment
c'est un des un des un des nombreux
travaux car ce n'est pas le seul qui
alimente la réflexion l'idée n'est pas
de repartir de zéro et de tout refaire
parce que c'est un rapport qui est
suscité pas mal de débats aussi à
l'époque il faut le faut le s'en
souvenir mais où effectivement les qui a
posé un état des lieux et former un
centre de propositions qui sont versées
pour celles qui ne sont pas encore mises
en oeuvre à la réflexion aux travaux
qu'est-ce que les assises apportent
c'est bien le périmètre est bien plus
large que la mission qui avait été
confiée à l'époque à l'IGAS vous l'avez
vu dans les les différents axes de
travail que je vous ai présenté
la santé mentale les populations
spécifiques voilà donc il y a une
ambition plus large encore n'ont pas que
celle de Liga c'était limité mais par
rapport à ce rapport
le ministre le ne nous a pas
le ministre affiche une grande ambition
et je dis pas ça par
langue de bois sur ce sujet là et pour
être totalement sincère si j'ai accepté
l'approvision qui m'a faite de présider
avec Christelle grale Owens comité
d'orientation alors que j'avais prévu
d'autres choses dans ma vie c'est parce
que j'ai senti qu'il y avait une
ambition réelle de non pas de d'adopter
quelques mesures paramétriques
comment on dit en ce moment mais bien
systémique et d'essayer vraiment de
refondre l'ensemble de du système donc
pas de pas non plus de c'est pas open
bar mais pas du tout de de censure ou de
ou de contraintes d'ordre budgétaire à
ce stade et c'est d'ailleurs le discours
que l'on tient aujourd'hui à nos pilotes
au stade où nous en sommes des travaux
et de la réflexion je ne veux pas que
l'on commence à s'auto censurer
ou à se dire que les choses ne seront
pas possibles etc voilà moi on rentre en
mêlée avec des idées non pas avec des
contraintes ou avec des problématiques
budgétaires avec des idées et puis après
vous savez bien comment se baptise des
politiques publiques on chemine les
administrations sont assez tôt dans les
discussions n'ont pas là non plus pour
contraindre ou censurer mais pour
justement commencer à travailler les
scénarios et qu'on puisse gagner du
temps sur la suite quelque chose ne se
fasse pas dans l'urgence quelques jours
avant les assises et que les arbitrages
ne soient pas couperaient donc voilà
c'est la méthode que l'on que l'on
utilise et vous avez évoqué
effectivement et merci de l'avoir fait
les mesures qui marchent les initiatives
locales qui pourraient voilà sur
lesquelles on peut et on a beaucoup
insisté on va le faire encore avec
Christelle auprès des pilotes et je me
permets de vous le redire parce que vous
êtes les mieux placés pour le faire nous
sommes très demandeurs
d'identifier parce que c'est souvent un
mal français que d'avoir du mal à
identifier ce qui marche au niveau
territorial de l'évaluer et puis
généralisée donc on va on va voir
comment vous prenez part à cette
réflexion dans les semaines à venir mais
je sais qu'il y a des initiatives
intéressantes innovantes dans vos
territoires et nous sommes très preneurs
vous puissiez les partager avec nous
pour qu'elles inspirent les propositions
que l'on pourra que l'on pourra faire
c'est la question de la vaccination je
n'ai pas non plus au ministère je n'ai
pas le bilan sur les vaccinations
obligatoires on pourra enfin de façon
c'est des choses qui font qui sont bien
évidemment réfléchies d'autant plus que
je crois comprendre qu'il y a des
velléités mais cristal reviendra
peut-être dessus de peut-être aller plus
loin encore sur la question des
vaccinations il y a encore il y a eu un
bon chemin de fait avec Agnès Buzin je
crois qu'il y a encore des perspectives
pour les années à venir donc c'est des
choses qui qui sont en tout cas
discutées on pourra se demanderait au
ministère de vous s'il existe un bilan
sur les vaccinations obligatoires
passées de vous pouvoir vous les trans
vous les transmettre enfin sur la
question de la chirurgie infantile à
Mayotte et les transferts
ça sera un des sujets je pense qu'il
sera évoqué par les professionnels de
santé et j'imagine les élus mais
notamment les professionnels de santé
que les pilotes du groupe ont prévu de
dictionner ils ne l'ont pas encore fait
mais il y a eu d'identification à un
certain nombre de professionnels de
santé de personnes d'administration
aussi type ARS et puis des lieux locaux
qui ont été identifiés dans chacun des
territoires chaque territoire ayant
aussi des spécificités des
particularités Mayotte n'est pas le
dernier à avoir un certain nombre de
problématiques à relever sur l'enfance
vous le savez bien mais c'est je ne
doute pas que ça sera un sujet qui sera
évoqué je ne sais pas si nous arriverons
à apporter une réponse définitive enfin
en tout cas je veux pas que ça sera
évoqué madame asiatrice
j'enchaîne Christelle et après je vous
rends la parole si ça vous ça vous
convient
madame la sénatrice pensée sur la
question du rythme scolaire
bon deux choses
vous avez raison je pense sur votre
votre analyse et votre constat c'est à
dire que cette question là un impact sur
beaucoup des autres sujets qui ont été
évoqués
vous avez vu que la façon dont nous
avons eu d'appréhender ses assises et
déjà
assez ambitieux et très large
je le dis c'est à la fois bien et c'est
un risque aussi
il y a un risque un de ne pas être au
rendez-vous des attentes que l'on a
suscité et puis deux de se noyer dans
des problématiques qui sont conséquentes
nombreuses diverses
donc nous allons nous atteler à essayer
de
répondre à toutes les problématiques que
nous avons soulevées je ne sais pas si à
ce stade nous pourrons en plus reformer
les refonts les rythmes scolaires mais
je ne doute pas et pour être honnête
c'est un sujet qui a déjà émergé dans
les discussions de façon très incidente
mais c'est un sujet qui a été évoqué
dans des dans des discussions qu'il y a
eu entre nous voilà et quand nous aurons
l'occasion de voir à pependent nous en
parlerons avec lui mais je vais pas
m'engager pour le ministre ce serait
bien mal venu et puis deux il faut aussi
peut-être aussi peut-être cadencé les
choses dans le temps c'est des gros
sujets qui peut-être nécessite d'être
évalués avant enfin sujet je maîtrise
pas non plus suffisamment pour être
totalement définitif ici
voilà et enfin Monsieur Beaune sur les
1000 premiers jours les 1000 premiers
jours n'apparaissent pas en tant que tel
mais sont évidemment et vous vous pouvez
imaginer que je suis j'insiste
lourdement dès que j'en ai l'occasion
pour Camille le premier jour fassent
bien l'objet de réflexion de
préconisations un peu l'étape 2 il y a
eu beaucoup de choses initiées ces
derniers temps là c'est quoi un peu
indépendant les acides c'est question
c'est quoi l'étape 2 des 1000 premiers
jours donc il y a toute une équipe
projet qui qu'on avait mise en place
très transversale très interministériel
la terre administration vraiment mode
projet très que j'ai trouvé très
efficace qui perdure qui continue à
travailler qui est sous la
responsabilité à la fois du ministre de
la santé mais aussi du ministre des
Solidarités qui a la qui a la tutelle
sur la famille et l'enfance
c'est partager entre deux
sur la question plus particulièrement
des PMI c'était aussi dans le cadre de
la stratégie nationale de prévention et
de protection de l'enfance que les PMI
avaient été devaient recevoir des moyens
je l'ai évoqué il y a eu des délégations
de compétences qui ont été très vite
inscrites au PLFSS de mémoire 2019 pour
dégager du temps médical
il y a eu dans la loi de
2022 si je ne dis pas de bêtises je
pense que c'est dans celle-ci la
tarification est de remboursement d'un
certain acte que faisaient les PMI en
lui et place des médecines scolaires
parce que dans certains départements
c'était la PMI qui assuré la médecine
scolaire et mais il y avait aucune
rémunération pour cela et ça a été
systématisé je crois que c'est dans la
loi de 2022 si je si je ne m'abuse et
puis dans le cadre de la
contractualisation entre l'État et les
départements sur cette stratégie
nationale de prévention et de protection
de l'enfance souvenez-vous un des
critères pour que les départs puissent
contractualiser étaient ils investissent
et qu'il réinvestissent dans leur PMI et
l'État
les amis à travers cette
contractualisation lors de ces trois
dernières années les 100 millions
d'euros que les PMI avaient perdu les 10
derniers les dix années précédentes donc
normalement
comme tout bon contrat il a été négocié
signé l'argent j'espérais est arrivé
dans les territoires et normalement les
départements ont les moyens et je vois
passer un syndrome de choses pour pour
moi après il y a un vrai problème de
recrutement des médecins mais là on
repart sur les sujets mais qu'on va
qu'on va devoir qu'on va affronter là
d'attractivité des médecins de PMI comme
on l'a sur la médecine scolaire de la
même façon bon voilà donc là il y a
beaucoup de réflexion en cours sur
comment rendre plus attractif ces
métiers ce qu'on fait de la
pratique partagée enfin bon il y a un
certain nombre de choses qui sont sur la
table qui sont en train d'être expertisé
qui sont dans lequel les départements
sur lesquels les départements devront
être associés enfin s'agissant
s'agissant en tout cas des médecins de
la médecine de PMI évidemment
voilà sur les bilans de santé
obligatoire oui sur l'aide sociale à
l'enfance vous avez raison c'est une
obligation légale depuis 2016 et alors
je ne sais plus si on l'avait évalué
très précisément à l'occasion du projet
de loi que nous avons partagé mais il y
avait des études qui ont déjà été faites
je n'ai plus le chiffre exact en tête
mais en gros c'est bilan de santé
obligatoire en entrée et de façon
régulière ne sont pas systématiques et
c'est loin de l'être et je sais même pas
si la moitié des enfants en bénéficient
donc c'est sujet sur lequel il est vrai
nous ne nous étions pas
particulièrement concentré à l'occasion
du projet de loi je suis pas sûr que ça
soit la loi qui réponde d'ailleurs à
cette problématique là et pour et pour
preuve on a eu beau l'inscrire dans la
loi en 2016 c'est pas ça qui a fait que
sur les dans les faits sur le terrain
les enfants bénéficient c'est donc c'est
l'occasion là typiquement de mieux
adresser ce problème et d'essayer d'y
répondre voilà parce que le sujet est
encore ouvert je l'admets totalement
et enfin sur santé protégé peut-être que
Christelle en dira un mot mais vous dire
que en tout cas il est prévu je crois
que qu'une présentation nous soit faite
enfin en tout cas on arrive un peu à un
stade de ces expérimentations et qu'on
regarde avec grande attention et
finalement sans tes protégé Pégase sur
un autre un autre champ pour voir comme
si à matière est généralisée ou pas mais
oui c'est bien c'est bien dans notre
parce que pardon Christelle je suis très
long si vous voulez compléter
merci je complète pour pour commencer
avec santé protégé puisque c'est c'est
probablement
un sujet dont on va reparler assez vite
c'est une expérimentation qui a été
financée au titre de l'article 51 qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur puisque
elle est portée par le CHU de Nantes et
par l'équipe de Nathalie Vabre qui était
à l'origine de de l'écriture de ce
travail conjointement avec avec d'autres
équipes qui nous ont rejointain c'est un
travail qui avance bien en dépit des
difficultés qu'on a pu rencontrer avec
la période covid il y a plus de 3000
enfants qui ont été inclus qui ont été
vus par des médecins de manière
régulière ces dernières années et qui
vont être
qui vont être présentés là le 24 mars
pour un premier bilan à Nantes et donc
cette journée est en cours
d'organisation les invitations vont
partir il est évident que cette
expérimentation elle est très très
attendu dans la mesure où non seulement
elle permet de pallier au fait que la
loi 2016 n'est pas été mise en oeuvre
dans les fêtes et que ces enfants pour
la plupart ne voyaient pas de médecin ou
de manière totalement décousue donc là
on va avoir et un intérêt concret pour
les enfants on va avoir une formation de
tous les spécialités les spécialités de
l'enfant qui ont participé des médecins
généralistes des pédiatres des médecins
PMI mais aussi tout Le les métiers du
médico-social qui ont été
confrontés à cette à cette prise en
charge et qui travaillent ensemble donc
il y a un intérêt pédagogique en termes
de formation de tous les professionnels
de l'enfant qui est énorme et puis bien
évidemment ça va être aussi une source
de chiffres très intéressants sur le
plan épidémiologique pour décrire la
santé de ses enfants depuis des années
on s'intéresse à décrire la santé
d'enfants par exemple prématuré on a
fait un peu un copier-coller de ces
travaux chez le prématuré pour pouvoir
décrire cette fois-ci la santé d'une
population très particulière
probablement un peu délaissé sur le plan
de leur santé somatique jusqu'à l'ordre
et qui aussi sur le plan de la santé
mentale relève de
prise en charge qui doivent être
optimisées donc sans tes protégé le
rendez-vous vous sera bien évidemment
communiquer pour le premier bilan qui va
être fait le 24 mars à la Faculté
médecine à Nantes et qu'on attend avec
impatience pour pouvoir je l'espère
prolonger cette approche qui est
bénéfique encore une fois pour les
enfants pour les professionnels qui s'en
occupent et pour notre connaissance de
leur état de santé donc voilà ce que je
pouvais vous dire sur santé protégé vous
avez aussi été
à plusieurs reprises intéressées par
bronchiolib qui est une autre approche
donc pour mémoire il s'agit d'organiser
la prise en charge des enfants porteurs
de bronchiolite
au sein d'un réseau de pédiatres
libéraux qui s'appuie sur des
puéricultrices qui vont à domicile
l'idée étant d'éviter le passage par les
urgences ou alors de raccourcir des
délais d'hospitalisation et donc c'était
expérimentation comme vous l'avez
mentionné elle a eu lieu hiver 2019 un
moment où c'était déjà difficile où les
services envoyé déjà des signaux
d'alerte elle a été mise en oeuvre très
rapidement de manière un peu précipitée
au début de la période épidémique ce qui
fait qu'il n'y a eu qu'une cinquantaine
d'enfants inclus et qu'il a été
difficile d'en tirer des généralités et
des conclusions définitives et
malheureusement la période qui a suivi
ne se prêtait pas du tout à poursuivre
cette expérimentation puisque il n'y a
pas eu de bronchiolite en hiver 2020 et
que cette année l'ampleur de la vague
était tel que tous les les
vous mettez saturé et que pour répondre
à votre question non cette
expérimentation n'a pas été reproduite
en 2022 tant le chaos était immense pour
autant ça reste une piste sur lequel on
souhaite vraiment travailler le rôle des
puéricultrices et leur articulation avec
la médecine libérale paraît
indispensable maintenant il faut
probablement élargir à pas uniquement
l'articulation avec les pédiatres mais
avec l'ensemble des médecins libéraux et
peut-être pas uniquement les
puéricultrices mais aussi des
infirmières qui seraient spécifiquement
formés et donc on a parlé de pouvoir
travailler dans l'axe 5 sur la formation
des professionnels de santé
autour des besoins spécifiques des
enfants et ça fera partie des travaux
qui sont amener mais des bonnes idées
sur lequel on tient vraiment à s'appuyer
et puis l'autre point sur lequel je
pouvais rebondir c'était dans dans
l'idée des travaux déjà disponibles et
des informations dont on dispose le
fameux rapport IGAS 2021 bien évidemment
qui qui n'est pas passé inaperçu c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire puisque comme
Adrien taquet vous l'a dit il est il est
pour je dirais 90% des propositions qui
ont été faites
il est tout à fait
consensuel mais un certain nombre de
propositions ne l'était pas et donc il
nous paraissait important de pouvoir y
revenir y retravailler et puis bien
évidemment ça n'est pas le seul document
sur lequel on va s'appuyer la Cour des
comptes a produit aussi un rapport qui
est très intéressant le Haut conseil de
santé publique a également des
recommandations qui sont qui sont en
cours et donc on va s'appuyer sur des
travaux qui sont beaucoup plus vastes et
les assises ne vont pas se contenter
d'appliquer les recommandations qui ont
été mentionnées allez bien de pouvoir
retenir celle qui sont les plus
consensuelles les plus adaptés et de
pouvoir l'élargir aussi à un domaine qui
est beaucoup plus vaste et puis enfin
pour ce qui est des vaccinations
obligatoires bonne nouvelle on dispose
des chiffres de couverture vaccinale qui
permettent de d'attester d'une
amélioration très spectaculaire de la
couverture vaccinale des enfants suite à
la mise en place de cette obligation
vaccinale on s'inquiétait du vécu des
parents et des protestations qui
pourraient y avoir et qui n'ont pas eu
lieu cette vaccination obligatoire elle
s'est déroulée dans le calme les enfants
aujourd'hui sont protégés contre les
maladies qui étaient qui étaient
possibles de protéger en 2018
puisque ça date de janvier 2018
maintenant pour autant aujourd'hui on a
un nouveau vaccin qui sont apparus on a
le vaccin contre le rotavirus on a le va
entre le ménago B et puis on est en
train de discuter de nouveaux produits
qui devraient te disponibles contre le
virus de la bronchiolite et quand vous
savez le chaos qui a été observé cet
hiver c'est probablement une approche
qui serait extrêmement intéressante pour
protéger en particulier les plus
fragiles ceux qui font les formes graves
de ponctualité
la difficulté qu'on rencontre depuis la
mise en oeuvre donc de cette obligation
vaccinale c'est que pour les produits
les vaccins qui ne sont pas dans la
liste des 13 vaccins obligatoires et
bien malheureusement
on a du mal là encore à communiquer à
informer les parents du bien-fondé d'un
vaccin contre la gastro-entérite contre
la méningite et celui qui qui s'annonce
pour les mois prochains qui est contre
la bronchiolite et donc on aura besoin
de nouveau de grandes campagnes de
communication d'information pour que les
familles sont convaincu de l'apport et
du bénéfice pour leurs enfants des des
produits qui ne sont pas dans
l'obligation vaccinale même si cette
mesure a été très spectaculaire en
termes de couverture vaccinale
alors nous avons encore si collègues bon
on devait finir à des heures je pense
que c'est plié mais on va continuer bien
évidemment donc Daniel Chassin Emilienne
pour mes rôles merci madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur le Ministre
madame le professeur pour donc ces
propositions plus réelles concrètes
j'espère vous mènera bien homogène une
seule question
concernant la santé mentale donc le
repérage des TSA bon c'est très bien
mais après bien sûr si on veut une
inclusion il manque actuellement et ça
on a des remontées des parents et des
mers pour pouvoir aider les enfants qui
sont inclus dans les classes il faudrait
que les ash soient
d'abord mieux rémunéré et puis qui
puisse prendre en charge l'interclasse
c'est ce qu'on a comme remonté
deuxièmement on a dans des départements
mais je sais que vous pouvez pas
d'un seul trouver des pédopsychiatres
mais il y a une carence vraiment très
très grave dans certains départements
ou malgré des postes qui sont une forme
il y a des postes qui ne sont pas
pourvus financer mais non pourvu et on a
beaucoup de demandes de la zone et aussi
des Maisons de l'Enfance à caractère
social est-ce que c'est un axe que vous
privilégiez pour essayer de remédier le
plus rapidement possible
merci moi une question de très brève
parce que vous l'avez déjà un petit peu
évoqué
on a parlé de la PMI on a parlé de la
médecine scolaire alors on a
effectivement de la difficulté on
voulait parler de redonner de
l'attractivité à ces deux métiers que ce
soit en médecine de PMI ou médecin
scolaires
il avait été prévu donc un rapport sur
la médecine scolaire et la possibilité
de départementalisation et c'est un
petit peu là-dessus que je voulais vous
interroger parce que
certes certaines départements ont des
difficultés à recruter des médecins de
PMI mais il y en a qui arrivent très
bien et qui se serait volontaire pour
prendre en charge cette compétences par
rapport à la médecine scolaire puisque
on peut dire qu'on a actuellement un
niveau de médecine scolaire qui vraiment
quand même assez dramatique
du peu de j'allais dire d'efficacité que
l'on peut avoir alors qu'il peut avoir
un rôle en dépistage et en prévention
extrêmement important et certains
départements se posent la question de
prendre la compétence donc au niveau du
département sur la médecine scolaire
d'autant qu'ils ont la compétence des
collèges et que donc il pourrait aller
jusqu'à au moins 16 ans faire faire
cette prévention j'aimerais savoir si ce
rapport alors je sais bien connaître
plus
au ministère mais ce rapport devait
sortir dans les six mois ils sont
largement passés est-ce que on va avoir
ce rapport et est-ce que vous savez ce
qui va en ressortir et est-ce qu'on va
donner les moyens bien sûr au
département s'ils reprennent de cette
compétence de l'exercice
Jocelyne guidez
c'est bon merci madame la Présidente
moi je voudrais parler des handicap
invisible
voilà parce que évidemment c'est
beaucoup plus difficile à détecter
puisque ils sont invisibles et moi j'ai
énormément de parents qui viennent me
voir aujourd'hui parce que tous les
frais associés à ces troubles ne sont
pas remboursés donc ça cause une
inégalité en tout cas à partir de d'un
très jeune âge et plus on tarde à les
détectée on sait très bien qu'au niveau
de la scolarité ça devient un prêt très
difficile pour attraper ce retard alors
moi je vais pas vous poser aujourd'hui
cette question parce que je sais que
c'est assez compliqué peut-être pour me
répondre aujourd'hui comment vous pensez
aller au devant de tout ça mais moi je
voudrais savoir si vous acceptez d'être
auditionné pour nos travaux par rapport
au TNT
Brigitte mikolo oui merci madame la
Présidente merci pour cette présentation
moi je voudrais connaître la place des
cancers pédiatriques et je voudrais
rebondir sur la situation
dramatique des l'hôpital des enfants à
Toulouse qui est en difficulté pour
assurer la mission de soins compte tenu
de la dégradation des ressources
humaines médicales voilà tout simplement
merci Laurence Rossignol et ensuite
Pascal bonnet pour terminer merci moi je
vais poser trois questions qui
concernent en fait le champ de votre
mission en particulier en matière de
santé mentale ou psychologique des
pré-ados et des ados enfant près de Hado
la première concerne des éléments qui
vont être je pense que je crois font
l'objet d'une étude du conseil de CFA
sur la médicalisation
médicamentation je sais pas comment on
dit voilà le la prescription de
médicaments
l'inflation de prescription de
médicaments auprès des enfants alors je
connais pas les résultats de l'étude
mais mon intuition et mon empire isme
conduirait à penser que c'est un
véritable sujet et qu'on observerait en
effet en matière effectivement de
troubles du comportement une inflation
de prescription inflation probablement
dû être en plus accrue par le covid et
les consultations et les prescriptions
en visioconférence
[Musique]
téléconsultation merci Emilienne voilà
ça c'est ce que vous avez est-ce que
c'est dans votre champ la deuxième
question concerne une autre concerne
également les préados et les ados il y a
un rapport de l'Académie de médecine qui
est sorti très récemment enfin moi je ne
connaissances très récemment sur
l'impact de l'exposition précoce à la
pornographie
sur la santé mentale des préados et des
ados est-ce que vous allez le prendre et
le troisième qui est plutôt chi je le
sais et puisque c'est la question de
savoir où se discute ou se discute
actuellement en France les questions des
traitements
hormonaux et aux chirurgicaux des ados
est prêt à dos en situation de
transition de genre pourquoi je pose la
question j'ai pas la réponse mais ce que
je sais c'est que pour les parents c'est
un vrai sujet parce que les parents sont
régulièrement soumis à des statistiques
probablement vrai de risques de suicide
et son prix en fait dans une question
qui est-ce que je dis est-ce que
j'accompagne puisqu'ils des enfants sont
des mineurs est-ce que j'accompagne
j'autorise traitement et chirurgie ou
est-ce que je prend le risque de voir
mon ado faire une tentative de suicide
et pour le moment j'ai l'impression que
tout ce signe tous ces discussions là se
passent en dehors même si je connais la
position de la HAS enfin je sais pas si
on va passer une position d'ailleurs
même conclusions d'un has là-dessus
est-ce que vous allez prendre est-ce que
le sujet va être traité chez dans votre
mission ou pas où est-ce qu'il est
renvoyé une autre instance ou est-ce
qu'il ne sera pas traité
terminé parce qu'elle Grigny
monsieur le Président et même la
présidente moi je voulais revenir sur la
bronchiolite parce que moi j'étais
fortement sollicitée par les réseaux des
kinés
qui en fait
ne peuvent plus théoriquement s'occuper
des enfants qui qui ont la bronchiolite
et pour bien connaître le réseau des du
Nord-Pas-de-Calais
le réseau était sollicité je sais que
sur un samedi ils ont eu 160 appels du
Samu pas des parents du SAMU et
normalement il pouvait pas prendre en
charge les enfants j'ai essayé
d'interroger le ministre je vous avoue
que je n'ai pas eu de réponse à ce jour
or j'ai entendu que vous vous sentiez
une expérimentation enfin il y avait une
expérimentation avec les infirmières les
puéricultrices mais les kinés
connaissent bien
et je sais que c'est plutôt la peur du
clapping mais les kinés font pas du
clapping n'importe comment et si on n'a
pas confiance dans ses professionnels de
santé je sais pas comment on peut faire
mais en tout cas il y a une information
qui est donnée au niveau de l'achat et
des CPAM comme quoi on fait il vaut
mieux éviter du coup les parents c'est
compliqué et du fait ils vont
directement aux urgences alors que pour
la bronchiolite finalement il y a plutôt
un apprentissage
au niveau des des parents donc ça c'est
vraiment important et puis juste aussi
parler des handicaps 10 voilà qui sont
enfin moi dans mon département il y en a
énormément et puis les CMPP qui n'ont
pas les moyens financiers qui pleurent
en fait pour avoir des journées
supplémentaires et le manque de
professionnels particulièrement les
psychomotriciens
voilà qui commence
Adrien si vous voulez je peux retirer
de pathologie oui je vous laisserai
aborder les questions moi médicales la
question de la kinésithérapie dans la
banque élite et extrêmement intéressante
puisque la SS a organisé une
recommandation qui a été publiée en 2019
et qui conclut que il n'y a pas
d'indications de kinésithérapie
respiratoire dans les formes de
bronchiolite
habituelles
pour
pour les nourrissons qui seraient
infectés par ce virus on était en effet
les seuls au monde à avoir cette idée de
faire de la kiné et il n'y a aucun
travaux scientifique qui atteste du
service rendu auprès des enfants ni des
familles en termes de éviter les
hospitalisations de diminuer les durées
d'hospitalisation ou la qualité de vie
donc à partir de cette observation
le groupe de la chaise
a conclu qu'il n'y avait pas de place
pour des techniques de kinésithérapie
respiratoires dans la bronchiolite
maintenant ça ne veut pas dire que les
kinésithérapeutes ne peuvent pas avoir
un rôle dans les épidémies telles que
celles qu'on a vécu et que ce rôle il
est il dépasse très largement la
question de la désobstruction des voies
aériennes puisque dans bronchiolite
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure il est
question d'aller aider une maman dont
l'allaitement est compliqué parce que
l'enfant de tête plus pendant plusieurs
jours il est question de s'assurer de
l'environnement de couchage de manière à
éviter les morts subites du nourrisson
il faut pouvoir peser l'enfant il faut
pouvoir avoir une approche beaucoup plus
globale que celle d'une seule technique
de kinésithérapie respiratoire et donc
c'est à ce titre que les
kinésithérapeutes peuvent certainement
être associés aux prises en charge mes
enfants mais pas du tout d'un point de
vue technique mais bien de l'aide à
l'allaitement de la surveillance de
l'état nutritionnel et aujourd'hui à ma
connaissance cela n'est pas enseigné
dans les écoles de kinésithérapie donc
on peut tout à fait envisager les
associés largement aux prises en charge
des bronchiolites sauf si elle
disparaissent grâce aux nouveaux
médicaments qui s'annoncent mais dans
tous les cas ça ne passe pas par des
gestes techniques mais bien par une
prise en charge beaucoup plus générale
de l'état de santé de l'enfant qui
aujourd'hui est possible pour des
puéricultrices mais qui nécessiterait un
enseignement spécifique des
kinésithérapeutes
voilà pour la question des kinés et puis
je peux peut-être répondre sur le point
qui évoquait le manque de ressources
médicales pour l'hôpital de Toulouse et
qui est un point extrêmement partagé par
l'ensemble des hôpitaux alors les
hôpitaux universitaires mais aussi les
hôpitaux généraux on n'a pas évoqué la
question des gardes de la permanence de
soi mais qui joue énormément dans
l'attractivité de ses postes et donc ça
sera bien évidemment un des sujets
majeurs qui sera abordés à l'occasion de
des Assises de la santé et puis le
dernier point sur lequel je peux dire un
mot c'est celui des prescriptions de
psychotropes
en lien avec l'aggravation la santé
mentale de des adolescents qui est
attesté par un certain nombre de travaux
épidémiologiques et qui a un point
d'alerte majeur sur lequel il faut qu'on
puisse ensuite travailler et modifier
nos pratiques puisque on est en décalage
par rapport aux autres pays européens de
manière très significative et on sait
que les Français en général consomment
plus de psychotropes que nos voisins
mais nos adolescents aussi et donc ça
c'est une vraie vraie préoccupation pour
ce qui est la question sur le transition
de genre je
pense que ça sera compliqué de pouvoir y
consacrer beaucoup de temps dans le
cadre de ces assises qui vous l'avez
compris vont avoir un
fardeau qui est très très intense et que
dans les trois mois on aura probablement
pas le temps d'y consacrer suffisamment
de de de travaux mais ça reste un sujet
majeur incontournable qu'il faut pouvoir
évoquer il me semble avec les
spécialistes du domaine donc des
psychiatres des pédopsychiatres mais
aussi des spécialistes en endocrinologie
de manière à pouvoir aborder cette
question difficile d'un point de vue
scientifique et pouvoir accompagner les
enfants et leurs parents dans ces
situations très compliquées donc on ne
pourra pas régler la question dans ses
assises mais c'est un sujet qui est
important
merci beaucoup
pour rebondir sur ce que vient et
prolonger ce que vient de dire
Christelle si on se projette un peu
effectivement sur ce que seront le point
d'interrrissage de ces assises on pourra
pas tout régler surtout c'est à dire
même sur d'autres politiques de
prévention si on se dit qu'il faut un
plan tabac par exemple on va pas arriver
je pense avec les 20 mesures du plan
tabac mais on dira que il y a un
problème de santé publique donc je pense
que la question que vous évoquez même
assez natrice Rossignol sur les
traitements hormonaux les transitions de
genre effectivement un sujet dont je
pense que il faut c'était un peu comme
ça vous avez présenté votre question à
un moment que le sujet soit abordé dans
une instance et qu'il y a un certain
nombre de cadres qui soit posé c'est pas
ces cadres on pourra peut-être en
énoncer le principe mais on n'aura pas
le temps effectivement de bien
établir établir les principes sur cette
question qui est qui est complexe
très rapidement sur les les
prescriptions médicales dans le cadre de
la santé mentale là aussi Christelle
Lavoine est revenu dessus on attend le
rapport du HCF effectivement qui porte
sur sur cette question
on va pas on va pas régler non plus
monsieur la question des aesh voilà même
si on a tous conscience et que c'est un
sujet qui revient sur le devant de la
scène tout ce conscience de l'importance
de de leur importance dans l'inclusion
des enfants en situation de handicap il
y a un vrai sujet vous l'avez dit sur la
pédopsychiatrie une façon générale
absence de pédopsychiatre et en
particulier sur les enfants de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance où il y a des
problématiques
qui sont qui sont importantes avec de
multiples multiples causes c'est un
sujet qui sera il y a il y a un point
dédié à la différence vous l'avez bien
compris et puis on a deux professionnels
que sont Anne-Catherine Laurent de Reims
et le professeur Bronsard de Brest qui
sont dans l'axe sur la santé mentale
mais qui par ailleurs ont beaucoup
travaillé travaillent beaucoup sur la
question des enfants protégés et donc
systématiquement et c'est très bien
parce que bien évidemment il y a ces six
axes mais il y a beaucoup de verape
entre les axes systématiquement pointe
la question de l'aide sociale en France
et de la question de la pédopsychiatrie
donc ça en tout cas il y aura une
attention particulière qui sera
qui sera portée
roll sur la médecine scolaire alors le
rapport IGAS je vais pas m'engager pour
eux il est il va sortir je crois dans
les semaines à venir voilà donc il est
le travail est en cours de finalisation
je crois de ce que j'en sais je n'en
connais pas le contenu très très
sincèrement on ne les a pas on les a pas
rencontrés donc je ne peux pas vous dire
le transfert de la médecine scolaire au
département une option une des option il
en est d'autres je ne sais pas du tout
dans quel sens je vais pas vous mentir
ou faire des faux espoirs dans quel sens
penche ce rapport sachant que on
l'intégrera nous dans nos travaux et
puis on aura nos des préconisations et
ensuite il y aura des arbitrages
ministériels nous on va proposer au
ministre une feuille de route enfin un
plan d'action et ensuite c'est lui le
ministre donc c'est lui qui va prendre
ses responsabilités de ministre et
décider sachant que sur ce sujet là
évidemment ça implique pas mal de monde
l'éducation nationale Le ministère de la
Santé évidemment les collectivités
locales d'une façon ou d'une autre
éventuellement sur la même façon sur les
réflexions sur la PMI où il y a
peut-être il peut y avoir peut-être des
bougies intéressantes qui peuvent être
faits et les deux sujets ne sont pas
dénués de liens vous avez raison de le
dire
Madame la satrice guidée sur les
handicaps invisibles typiquement sur ces
sujets là enfin qui sont qui sont qui
sont connus mais qui parfois vont se
nicher dans les dans les angles morts ou
les ou les faces sombres de la
République comme on dit il faut vraiment
ne pas hésiter vous et les personnes
avec qui je dis ça de façon un peu
général les associations que vous
rencontrez etc faites-le évangéliser un
peu s'il vous plaît en autre nom et pour
nous sur la tenue de ces assises et sur
la nécessité pour ces personnes pour ces
associations de nous remonter de nous
pointer des difficultés des points
spécifiques de nous et de nous remonter
des propositions surtout j'insiste là
dessus vraiment voilà donc à travers les
à travers vous ou à travers les outils
et des pas à travers vous et les parents
isolés peuvent aussi contribuer tout élu
on va en on a des ressources pour que
tout soit traité via la plateforme dont
je vous pouvez retrouver sur le site de
la Société française de pédiatrie ou du
ministère c'est c'est accessible
vraiment homepage parce que l'adresse
c'est très peu compliqué en elle-même
ils peuvent contribuer tout ça et pris
en considération vraiment je vous en
garantis et avec plaisir je sais pas à
quel titre mais pour être additionné par
pour votre commission sur les TND mais à
ce titre là au titre de ma participation
au quatrième plan à l'élaboration avec
un plan stratégie autiste on trouvera
mais avec grand plaisir ces sujets qui
me sont qui me sont toujours chers et
puis voilà
merci merci beaucoup à tous les deux de
nous avoir présenté ces assis c'était en
effet on avait évoqué lorsqu'on s'était
appelé monsieur le ministre il est
important que la Commission puisse être
au fait de la méthode de l'échéancier
mais aussi de tous les actes sur
lesquels vous allez travailler et bien
évidemment si on a des contributions à
vous faire on vous les apportera que ce
soit les groupes de travail aussi un
groupe à la commission de la culture sur
les aesh qui va se mettre en place donc
beaucoup de sujets qui ont très à
l'enfance vont être pris en compte par
les différentes commissions également
par le groupe handicap donc merci
beaucoup et à bientôt alors